thank you for joining us America's josh
is with us in fort myers florida hi Josh
how are you I'm doing fantastic Dave how
about yourself better than I deserve
what's up
I got a 401k question I've been with
corporations all my career so everywhere
I went if somebody's always had a 401k
program where I basically it was just
roll over your money into this new
program I left my job well I started
with a independent franchise owner and
so I got a 401k money rolled over to me
in the form of a check oh no and
apparently you're supposed to find
somewhere to put them within a certain
amount of time yeah and you didn't even
get the hold you don't even get the
whole amount they withheld 20% on you
yeah so I have two checks on my desk in
my office and now I'm wondering what the
world is on at number two we we are on
day one of maybe step number two this is
our first month okay so I'm wondering no
I don't use this money any money you use
out of that 401k is going to cost you
your tax rate plus a 10% penalty so it's
going to be 35 or 40 percent hit on this
money and so you wouldn't borrow money
at 35 or 40% to use it so the problem
you've got is this when you take that
check they withheld 20% on you you have
60 days to put a hundred percent of your
401k into an IRA or you're going to be
taxed and penalized on whatever you
don't put in there but you don't even
have a hundred percent you've only got
eighty percent so that's why this is a
major error how much money is involved
here about forty thousand okay and so
that that was what was in the 401k or
that's what they sent you
well then forty thousand was over then I
got a check for thirty seven thousand
three hundred seventeen forty seven
thousand what was in there thirty-seven
I'm sorry yes you're correct yeah yeah
they would have because they had to
withhold 20 percent on you which would
be about eight grand on a forty thousand
dollar deal so yeah your sum
we're up in the 46 foot was your balance
or something like that so you've got an
eight thousand dollar problem right now
so what I want you to do is real quickly
how when did you get that check January
of this year or you're already screwed
yes exactly
yeah you had 60 days to roll it you
didn't roll it you've cashed it out yeah
that's right that's what I was basically
told was oh you had 60 days of course
obviously we're way past that point now
now I have two checks there and I mean
I'm thinking well I'm already in trouble
yeah but I just total I'm already in so
now we're not in trouble you just got
taxes of probably 16,000 bucks
and penalties on this money and so and
of that you've already paid 8,000 so you
got about another 8,000 once UK but
you've never even cashed the check no
why you know it was one of those things
we had a nice in November and you know
lack of sleep I don't know excuse really
just got shuffled up or some paperwork
and then when cleaning up the desk it
was just kind of like oh how do I do
this but you know I was like I see
that's like a $16,000 shuffle uh ouch
so let's do this to verify but I'm 90%
sure you're going to have pay you're
going to cash the check and you're going
to show you is going to show up in your
taxes this year and you're going to get
hammered for taxes and penalties on this
okay of which you've already paid some
with the amount they amount they
withhold but that's other than that so
what's your household income my wife and
I combined about 100 thousand now you're
going to get hit for easily sixteen so
probably but let's verify that what I
want you to do to see if there's any
loophole that I don't know about in the
technicality of that you haven't cashed
the check maybe there's a technicality I
doubt it but let's just check and see
since there's a $16,000 screw up here
maybe you can sidestep it I doubt it but
let's ask go to smart Wester on Dave
Ramsey comm click on it put your zip
code in it'll drop down
a series of people called smart Wester
pros that I recommend for investing they
don't work for me
but they're the people we recommend for
investing they do the stuff the way we
teach you get in touch with one of them
freaking today okay do not delay one
minute and get on the phone and talk to
them and see if there's anything that
they know of that you can do on this to
actually still pull it off as a rollover
since the check has not been cashed can
you you know get in touch with your old
company have them reissue it instead of
as a check this time let it be a
rollover direct transfer into a mutual
fund IRA which is what you should have
done and maybe there's a slight chance
you can do that since the check hadn't
cleared but I doubt it
I think you're probably hammered but
with the penalties but let's check with
a professional in the business because
I'm not in the business and they can
look at the technicalities and see if
they can if you can sidestep this but
otherwise you're just going to cash the
check you're gonna pay the penalties and
basically you cashed your 401k out so
what you did and which was really a
stupid move $16,000 worth of stupid
which by the way I've done a lot of
stupid things in my life so I'm not I'm
not just picking on you up you know Josh
I've done Dumber things than that but
when I do stupid stuff and I write a
check for it always put stupid tax on
the four column of the check and that's
what this 16 grand is or so here that I
think you're going to get hit for ouch
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]